good morning believe nation today's
messages go out and learn something over
to you Gordon Ramsay my advice to young
chefs from the age of 16 to sort of 2930
is 14 years of a sponge you're absorbing
knowledge don't take a job for the sake
of money don't worry about earning 500
pound a month for a year more somewhere
else
go and get knowledge because that
becomes a bigger passport Frehley
thinking the money will come once you've
mastered your craft and you become you
Clary talented work for big chefs and
find a difference level of conflict when
things get too comfortable and you're
still living with your parents and
you've still got your first job and you
want to move out because everything's to
cover get out put yourself in a strange
situation in the middle of Barcelona for
yourself in the middle of Paris put
yourself in the middle of Belgium and
see what's available that's amazing how
much comfort it gives you more
importantly it's great to eat and travel
at the same time fantastic
Marlene success saved my business when I
was 19 and struggling and making no
money and wanted to quit it was Bill
Gates's strategies that saved my company
and it was me realizing that I don't
need to know everything I can learn it
from somebody who's already accomplished
it and the fastest way to grow is to
find somebody who's already done
whatever goal you want to achieve and
model them whether that's go work for
them and and be mentored by them and be
with them and you go find that
entrepreneur who has 10 employees or
less who's done what you want to do and
get as close to them as possible or
whether it's looking to aspirational
mentors you know people who you look up
to people who you've never met people
who may have already passed on I look up
this Steve Jobs and Walt Disney and if
you Giannini people have taught me
things even though I've never met them
and never will because if you just try
to figure everything out yourself you're
probably not gonna make it you don't
have the skills and expertise and the
resources right now but you can get them
you can acquire that knowledge by going
out there and understanding the people
who have done it and modeling their
success to make it work for you
believe so the question that a today is
I want to know who you have modeled for
your business who have you looked up to
and taken a strategy from them and
applied it to your business leave it in
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events preso